welcome back to Quantum Computing in practice I'm your host Olivia Lanes last time we walked through an example of a
Quantum Computing approach to an optimization problem known as Max cup using the Cubo formulation we went
pretty far in depth but that was just one example of one approach today we are going to discuss near-term applications
more broadly and develop our intuition for different types of problems we expect to find useful Quantum solutions
for and see some recent examples of some important work done in our community at a utility
scale previously we briefly discussed that not all problems have the need for additional computational power
specifically Quantum Computing in order to be solved efficiently these are the problems that you're already most
familiar with arithmetic scrolling social media maybe playing Tetris Doom or other video games we broadly consider
these easy problems on the other hand there are very hard problems such as finding prime factors of enormous
integers and this is the basis of RSA encryption and what sh's algorithm was actually designed to solve another
example is finding a solution in an unsorted data set this can theoretically be solved by the quantum algorithm known
as Grover's algorithm however most experts agree that these types of algorithms will necessitate the
implementation of error correction and we're just not there yet technologically speaking so as we go forward in this
lesson and in your Quantum educational Journey remember we are looking for this Sweet Spot somewhere here in the middle
it's a hard problem to crack but that's also what makes it so fun one thing we've not yet discussed
much is computational complexity Theory one of the reasons being is that it can be somewhat intimidating and yes
complex computational complexity theory is the field of computer science that aims to classify computational Problems
by how difficult they are are a ton of different complexity classes in classical Computing but the most
fundamental are these P problems these were problems that can be solved in polinomial time at the scale as the
problem increase meaning that they are easy to solve the next more difficult type of problem is NP problems which
stands for non-deterministic polinomial these are problems whose answers can be verified in polinomial time but not
necessarily solved next is NP comp complete and now we're getting into the really challenging problems with no
known polinomial solution this is where famous problems like the traveling salesman problem and even the game
Sudoku live now when Quantum Computing came to be at least in theory people spent a considerable effort trying to
figure out what class of problems these new types of computers would be able to solve efficiently a new class of
problems were invented called bounded error Quantum polinomial problems or bqp for short their strict definition is a
little long but it is the class of decision Problem solvable by a quantum computer in polinomial time with a small
chance of error there's a chance of error because Quantum measurement is inherently random but the error
probability can be arbitrarily small now all of these classes live in a larger class we call pspace and this is where
we think bqp lives relative to all of the other types of problems but it's very hard to definitively prove this
mathematically you'll notice that bqp Quantum problems do not necessarily overlap with NP complete problems
however you might have still seen some Quantum Computing approaches that aim to solve NP complete problems why would
this be one common misconception is that there is no point in exploring solutions
to problems like the traveling salesman and other NP complete problems for a quantum computer or any problem or a
mathematical proof for a Quantum speed up has not been found however this doesn't necessarily have to be the case
finding mathematical proof that a Quantum algorithm is faster than its classical counterpart is rare Shore and
Grover are two of the only handful of examples where this has been done so far but that is okay in fact computer
scientists still haven't even been able to prove that the classes of p and NP are different even though all intuition
tells us that they must be also comparing two algorithms and how they scale often looks at the worst case
scenario for each it is quite possible that in practice the worst case scenario is not what we find in real life so we
do not despair we introduce instead the idea of heuristic Solutions if you're an
experimentalist you already know and love these types of solutions a heuristic is any approach to solving a
problem that is pragmatic but not necessarily optimal and that's great because Solutions don't necessarily have
to be optimal in order to be very useful for instance think about a financial application we haven't yet found an
exponential speed up for most Financial algorithms that Quantum could be used for yet but that doesn't necessarily matter we don't need an optimal solution
in finance at least because a solution that is even just 1% more efficient could equate to billions of dollars
worth of profit so how do we know what use cases and problems could be suitable for Quantum Computing right now and by that
I mean there's significant reason to believe Quantum utility or even Advantage could be found either now or
in the somewhat near future maybe it's easier to first name things that the problem should certainly not have it
can't require a huge number of cubits we don't have processors yet that have thousands to millions of cubits available that's one of the main reasons
Shores algorithm and the like are so far off the circuits also can't be incredibly deep it's really hard for me
to tell you exactly what circuit depth won't work because it depends on so many factors but in general if your
experiment requires a depth that you haven't seen achieved in the literature yet you might be in for a rough time and
lastly any type of algorithm that we know will require error correction cannot be done yet what we should look for however are experiments that make
use of most of the cubits available on any given qpu we have also emphasize the
importance of error mitigation and suppression and lastly there should be an obvious extension to Future
applications that would be important for society and that we could see eventually leading to Quantum
Advantage now let's talk about some examples of use cases which fall into three main categories that we have
identified as most likely to see favorable outcomes in the near to Middle
term the first area is the simulation of nature we've spoken about this previously there
are so many opportunities for quantum computers to improve the research being done on the molecular and atomic level